could one quirky comedy actor have had a
completely different career had he
starred in Donnie Darko you may be
surprised how much can change when an
actor turns down a roll Marvel Studios
wanted to make a thunderous impact with
its new Cinematic Universe back in 2008
so it set out to employ a few big names
for its debut feature Iron Man one of
the first to sign up was actor Terrence
Howard they' been nominated for an
Academy Award a few years earlier for
his performance in Hustle and Flow he
was cast as Tony sark's best friend
James RH an Air Force pilot who in the
comics eventually becomes an armored
hero himself named War Machine though
Howard didn't suit up in Iron Man the
clear implication was that to get his
shot in the sequel but any plans to do
so was scrapped when the studio
attempted to slash his fee for Iron Man
2 the actor refused to budge in
negotiations and Marvel responded by
simply firing him and bringing in
Ocean's 11 star Don cheel as his
replacement Howard later said that this
Ting orbit destroyed his career he would
eventually rebound
starring in the fox drama Empire
beginning in 2015 but there's no denying
that his movie career took a massive hit
after missing out on Iron Man 2 cheedo
meanwhile went on to play roads in a
pair of Iron Man sequels he also
apprised the part in Captain America
Civil War Two Avengers movies and a
couple Disney plus series he slated to
take the lead in his own Marvel movie
armor Wars though it doesn't have an
official release date as of early
2024 initially a quasi sequel to the
1968 Thriller the detective 1988's Die
Hard evolved into its own action movie
this Leb producers to look for a big
name to play the film to solusion cop
John mlan in addition to established
movie stars the studio also looked at
Big names from the small screen
eventually settling on Moonlighting star
Bruce Willis he wasn't the first choice
though Don Johnson of Miami Vice Fame
was initially offered the role for
whatever reason Johnson passed and
Willis stepped in eventually leading to
what is now considered one of the best
action movies of all time from there
Willis orbert put TV behind him and was
one of the biggest box office drawers of
the 1990s starring in pop fiction 12
Monkeys Armageddon and The Sixth Sense
he also reprised the role of mlan in
four Die Hard sequels Johnson meanwhile
continued on Miami Vice through 1989 but
his career stored out from there he made
a comeback in 1996 with his TV series
Nash Bridges which lasted a strong six
seasons but he never did find the
Blockbuster movie success that is
replacement Bruce Willis did in the
early 2000s Rachel dra made a name for
herself on Saturday Night Live with
characters like Debbie Downer and was
ready to take the next step in her
career after leaving the show in 2006
aiming to grab a leading role on a hit
TV sitcom she discovered that her SNL
compatriot Tina Fay had created a part
just for her in the semi-biographical
workplace comedy 30 Rock after filming
the pilot episode however the decision
was made to ditch Dr in favor of Jane
Kowski who went on to play pompous
actress Jenna for Seven Seasons
dra never rebounded sadly though she did
make a series of guest appearances on 30
Rock in a variety of different roles
eventually she turned to voice acting
where she found success on Fish Hooks
The Awesomes and imaginary Mary among
others Dr doesn't seem to struggle for
work but there's no telling where her
career might be had she not been
scratched from the Emmy awardwinning 30
Rock oh well I hadn't thought of that
that's the thing so few do
along with the likes of Breaking Bad and
Mad Men the effects crime drama Sons of
Anarchy helped to usher in a wave of
prestige TV drama in the late 2000s and
Charlie Hunnam was at the center of it
all for Seven Seasons he starred on Sons
of anaki as Jax Teller head of a
dangerous motorcycle gang from there he
became a genuine International sex
symbol with a mix of bad boy charm and
rugged good looks drawing the shows run
he'd already taken a shot at the Silver
Screen starring in films such as Pacific
Rim when Sons of Anarchy ended it seemed
that nothing would stop him a few
failures however cut him down to size
this included the disastrous attempt at
a Cinematic Universe in King Arthur
legend of the sword and an ill-advised
remake of papon but he almost had a
chance to assert his box off his
dominance when he was offered the role
of Christian Gray in the controversial
adaptation of the erotic novel 50 Shades
of Gray despite his enthusiasm for the
film hunam had to leave the project due
to scheduling conflicts it was quickly
replaced by Jamie Doran and there the
moments that h admitted has haunted him
ever since while he starred in
interesting films like Crimson Peak and
triple Frontier he still never found a
project that's been a successful as 50
Shades sometimes there's no better way
to fill a role in a movie than to cast
an acto who's already played a similar
character to Greater claim that was the
case when the producers of gree set out
to find an actor to play leather
jacketed Greaser and teen Rebel Danny
Zuko for their big screen adaptation of
the classic musical their first choice
was Henry Winkler he'd already become a
star on television for playing the a
similar character Arthur funzi ferelli
in a generational sitcom Happy Days
concerned about typ casting Winkler
declined cuz I'm the F the part instead
fell to John Travolta whose breakout hit
Saturday Night Fever hadn't even been
released when he snagged the role at the
time it might have seemed like the right
move for Winkler whose career playing
the funds on the small screen continued
and abated until the mid 80s but Greece
helped cut Ault revolter to movie Legend
status while Winkler was mostly stuck on
television Winkler has thankfully found
plenty of success of his own over the
years most recently earning a claim for
his role in HBO's Barry but he's acutely
aware of the fact that he might have
become a bigger Star had he said yes to
Danny Zuko he told Newsweek I went home
and had an orange juice John Travolta
said yes to the role and he went home
and bought a plane in the late 1980s
through the 1990s Christina Applegate
was a TV sitcom star appearing as
daughter Kelly Bundy in Married with
Children during the show's 11 season run
she attempted to make the jump into the
movies but didn't have much success
starring in disappointments like Don't
Tell Mom the Babysitter's Dead
vibrations and a bit roll in the Tim
Burton flop M attacks in 2001 she was
offered the lead in The Comedy Legally
Blonde but perhaps due to a spotty track
record and apparent need to pick her
projects more carefully she hesitated
feeling like it was too much like her
role as Kelly Bundy she chose not to do
the film as we know now Applegate's
decision to pass on the project wound up
being a major blunder Legally Blond was
a massive hit and helped her replacement
ree Witherspoon breakout in Hollywood
Applegate told Vanity Fair many years
later I wouldn't toy with the idea of
Legally Blonde because it felt too fresh
getting out of Married With Children it
was very similar on paper looking back
the actor eventually concluded that
passing on the role of L was a mistake
aside from the money she would have made
missing Legally Blonde shut down her
chances of other big movies as
Witherspoon went on to become a box
office star from Rocky to Rambo
Sylvester Stallone was one of the
biggest action heroes on the scene in
1993 he went sci-fi for Demolition Man
where he played a 20th century cop named
John Spartan who was cryogenically
frozen and unored in 2032 with the help
of a young female officer in the future
police force he must track down a deadly
killer from his past first Stallone
sidekick the movie casts of mostly
unknown actor Sandra bulock but she was
actually a replacement for Lori Petty
who was fired after just 2 days of
shooting at the time Petty was coming
off a star turn in the baseball movie A
League of Their Own and according to
variety she was fired due to creative
differences with producer Joel Sila
though Petty did Rebound with tang girl
a couple of years later which became a
cult classic in its own right the bulk
of her subsequent career has been in
smaller indie films supporting roles and
television while she's carved out a nice
niche for herself over the years Petty
never did match the heights of Bullock
whose part in Demolition Man helped
rocket her to fame when Terry Farrell
was cast to play Trail signs of officer
Jadzia Dax on Star Trek Deep Space 9 she
was almost entirely unknown now part of
an iconic sci-fi franchise Farrell St to
grew and after 6 years as Lieutenant Dax
she wanted to explore other
opportunities producers weren't
interested in reducing her appearances
so they AED her from the show and
replaced her with Nicole dor in the
immediate aftermath farell did snag a
leading role in Becca alongside sitcom
Legend Ted Danson but after a solid few
seasons Becca bottomed out and career
never recovered she spent years in a war
of words with Tre producers who claimed
she had been greedy during contract
negotiations while it's tough to say if
Farrell could have continued in bigger
roles had she stuck around for the final
season of Deep Space 9 her and
ceremonious exit did her no favors by
2003 Farrell was almost entirely out of
acting and she still counts Lieutenant
Dax as her biggest role on my beloved
old friend I'm Jing now if you're at
allall familiar with actor Richard ke
it's almost certainly thanks to his role
as Jaws in a pair of iconic James Bond
films the spy who loved me and Moonraker
at a towering 7'2 in ke was often
brought in to play imposing characters
like the steel tooth Jaws so when the
Incredible Hulk TV show needed a
behemoth of an actor to play the titular
Jade giant he was the obvious choice
after filming for a few days however it
became obvious that K sheia height
wasn't enough looking for someone with
the bulk and mass of the musclebound
green Goliath he was dismissed and in
came bodybuilder Lou fno after joining
The Incredible Hulk fno became
synonymous with the character continuing
in the role for all five seasons and
three subsequent TV movies he even
voiced a character in a 1996 animated
series and returned to provide the big
screen Grunts and growls for Marvel's
The Incredible Hulk in 2008 as for Keel
he once claimed that he didn't regret
losing the role because the experience
of shooting the pilot episode of The
Incredible Hulk was extremely unpleasant
for him nevertheless it left him
relegated to smaller parts and while he
did manage to appear in a handful of
memorable movies nothing ever made him
as famous as Forno's angry Green Giant
you wouldn't like me when I'm angry in
2008 Paul Thomas Anderson said Willl Be
Blood received eight Academy Award
nominations and won two including best
actor for Daniel D Lewis the film also
wound up being a turning point in the
career of Paul Doo who played the Dual
roles of identical twins Paul and Eli
Sunday the roles helped establish him as
an up and cominging star leading to
movies like 12 years of slave and the
Batman but his career may have turned
out very differently if the first actor
chosen for the role hadn't walked away
just weeks into filming that actor was
Kell O'Neal and while rumors persisted
that the inexperienced sespan had quit
because it felt intimidated by D Lewis
the truth is far more mundane not
feeding up to the rigers of the role
O'Neal decided to leave and the
producers agreed Paving the way for
doa's introduction into the film since
then O'Neal has largely disappeared from
acting with his last onscreen appearance
coming in 2010 despite how it impacted
his career O'Neal doesn't seem to regret
losing out he felt that acting
ultimately wasn't a fit for him so he
moved behind the camera to direct the
Empire project in 2012 speaking about
Anderson in an interview for PBS's POV
interactive shorts he explained if he
hadn't fired me from their Will Be Blood
I would probably still be an actor
dreaming of making my own films one of
the biggest sitcom hits of the early
'90s the fresh prince of Belair was led
by Young Will Smith as the aonomus Royal
team from West Philadelphia for the
first three seasons it was actor Janet
Hubert who played his Aunt Vivian Banks
but she was booted from the series and
replaced by Daphne Maxwell Reed
conflicting stories about Hubert's
departure made the rounds with the actor
tossing dirt at Network Executives who
she believed had it out for her Smith
however had a different story he claimed
it was actually Hubert's behavior on the
set that led to her firing adding that
she wanted the show to be more about her
than the title character he even alleged
that she had referred to him as a
snot-nosed Punk and that she was mad he
got his own show whether it was her
attitude or just her exit itself Hubert
struggled to find more regular work in
the aftermath she fell into a series of
single episode guest Parts on various TV
shows including Coach Dave Weld and The
Pretender it wouldn't be until 2005 that
she'd even have a regular role on TV
again this time on the daytime soap One
Life to Live it was far from the network
sitcom success should w enjoyed more
than a decade earlier if you're a fan
of' 80s movies you may be familiar with
Deborah Winger who appeared in some of
the biggest films at decade from Urban
Cowboy and legal legal to romantic
dramas Like An Officer and a Gentleman
in terms of endearment she could be seen
in hits after hit the 1990s weren't as
good to her though and it seems that
when the decade had turned over so toed
her career but if she hadn't walked away
from one of the biggest comedies of 1992
it might have been very different cast
have played dty in A League of Their Own
Winger actually spent months prepping
with the Chicago Cubs to learn the game
of baseball but when Pop Star Madonna
got the role of May Winger bed and quit
the film in protest despite collecting a
paycheck for her work she was replaced
by Gina Davis who had just earned an
Academy Award nomination for Thelma and
Louise when all was said and done A
League of Their Own collected more than
$130 million at the box office and Davis
turned in a Golden Globe nominated
performance in Winger's old role Winger
herself never starred in a blogbuster
film ever again again there's no crying
in baseball the Hogan Family might be
one of the 1980s most underrated sitcoms
airing for six seasons between 1986 and
1991 it starts Sandy Duncan his Aunt
Sandy who arrives to take care of her
three precocious nephews after the death
of her sister but the Hogan Family
actually started out under the name
Valerie and initially starred Valerie
Harper from The Mary Tyler Mo show and
Roa she played a busy housewife and
mother however due to a bitter contract
dispute between Harper and the shud stud
over a pay increase her character was
killed off after the second season in
the aftermath Sandy Duncan was brought
in to lead the show for four more years
and though it didn't Propel Duncan to
super stardom by any metric Harper's
contentious dismissal did effectively
end her days as a sitomer while she did
get the last laugh in the courtroom
suing the studio and ultimately
receiving a million dollar settlement
for wrongful termination her career as a
leading lady was all but over perhaps
Studios were leery about hiring her
after the debacle but whatever the case
Valerie was the last time Harper would
star in her own series aside from the
shortlived 1990 show City Rachel Lee
Cook first gained attention for starring
in the baby tits Club in 1995 the more
hit team flick brought her to Greater
prominence these included leading roles
in all I want to do with Kiron dun and
Gabby Hoffman and of course her star
turn and she's all that opposite Freddy
Prince Jr in 1999 she had a chance to
become a true Superstar a year later
when she was picked by director Brian
Singer to play Rogue in the first X-Men
film but she turned down the offer
instead of cook it was Anna pacn who
nabs the part and the replacement star
would go on to appear in four X-Men
films pacquin turned that Fame into a
lead role in True Blood and 20 years
later Cook's career is hardly much by
comparison looking back in 2021 she
called the decision not to play Rogue a
huge misstep and just not difficult to
understand why but according to cook she
was being advised to pick her rolls
carefully for fear of not being taken
seriously she told Insider I definitely
did things for the wrong reasons
wait it's not over yet the decision to
pass on X-Men becomes all the more
perplexing when you realize she instead
chose to star in the box office flop
Josie and the Pussycats in the early
2000s there were a few hotter names and
Rising Star Josh Harnet after breaking
out in hits like Pearl Harbor and
Blackhawk Down hardnet met with director
Christopher Nolan to discuss the
possibility of taking on the title role
in Batman Begins but comic book movies
didn't have a good reputation at the
time and fearing it might actually hurt
his nassin career the actor took himself
out of consideration American Psycho
star Christian Bale was eventually cast
as a Caped Crusader the film made Bale a
Bonafide aister while turning Nolan into
one of Hollywood's hottest directors
hardnet meanwhile missed a chance to
rebound from his failure on Hollywood
Homicide and instead starred in The
Notorious flop lucky number seven open
about his regret for bypassing the
chance to be Batman hardnet made no
secret that the movie was a big mistake
that hurt his career he even felt it put
him on the outs with Nolan hard told
Playboy in 2015 he didn't want to put me
in the prestige they not only hired
their Batman for it they also hired my
girlfriend at the time nearly two
decades later the director and actor
have apparently patched things up as
Nolan gave haret a role in 2023 is
Oppenheimer Christopher Nolan wasn't a
bigname director when he chose to take
on a new series of Batman films in the
2000s the cage Crusader hadn't been
doing all that well himself the
character's previous alting 1997's
Batman and Robin is often reviled as one
of the worst superh hero movies ever
made Nolan wanted to bring the
grittiness back in a grounded and
realistic take that could make audiences
believe a billionaire would dress up
like a bat to fight crime when Nolan set
about casting 2005's Batman Begins
Christian Bale wound up being the
perfect choice and Chin for the role and
standing next to him was Katy Holmes
then best known for starring in the TV
series Dawson's Creek the film went on
to be a massive hit and it was no
surpris that a sequel followed in 2008
but while the rest of the cast returned
there was one conspicuous
ktie Holmes had been replaced by Maggie
Gyllenhaal as Rachel it's always been
unclear as to why Holmes didn't appear
in the dark night Nolan said he wanted
her to return but she was unavailable
Holmes meanwhile later said it was her
choice not to come back and while she
expressed that she didn't regret it she
hasn't been in many high-profile films
since the Dark Knight remains one of the
major releases of its decade maybe
returning for the sequel wouldn't have
given homes's career the Boost it needed
but it sure couldn't have hurt Harrison
Ford was one of the true Mega stars of
the 19 1980s thanks in large part to
starring roles in two of the Decades
biggest franchises Star Wars and Indiana
Jones the latter is in many ways Ford's
own personal franchise more than four
decades after the original Raiders of
the L St 2023 is Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny still featured Ford as
the archaeological Action Hero so it may
come as a bit of a surprise that
originally Ford wasn't meant to play the
part producer George Lucas had already
worked with him on American Graffiti and
Star Wars and wasn't interested in doing
so a third time so Tom CK was offered
the part unfortunately he landed two
roles simultaneously not only Indiana
Jones but also the lead in the CBS TV
show Magnum PI the network refused to
let their new star delay filming in
order to shoot Raiders and Stak was
forced to turn down the job no choice In
fairness Magnum PI was a huge hit show
and made Cel a TV star but it never
really led to a big screen bounce for
him Ford meanwhile continued to lead
dramatic and action movies for decades
and Indiana Jones remains one of
Cinema's most beloved Adventure Heroes
Magnum was a good show and celic has
done others but his star could have been
far brighter if it War a fedora one of
the biggest cult hits of the early 2000s
Richard Kelly's Donny Darko starred Jake
Gyllenhaal as a trouble teen dealing
with visions of a monstrous rabbit and
the complexities of time travel the 2001
film wasn't a big hit in theaters but it
became an instant cult classic on home
video and gyllen Hall gained attention
with his Moody performance it may
surprise some to learn that it was
actually Jason schwarzman who was first
cast in the role in fact it was his
presence on the project that actually
got the movie made in the first place
unfortunately Le you to scheduling
conflicts schwarzman had to drop out at
the 11th Hour Kelly was forgiving
knowing the film never would have been
green lit without the Rushmore star and
gyllen Hall stepped in in hindsight it's
easy to see why his departure was a
mistake as schwarzman instead went on to
starring Slackers an unfunny and
forgotten teen sex comedy he struggled
to land another hip before finding his
niche in quirky comedies reuniting with
Rushmore director Wes Anderson for
2007's a diling limited and The Grand
Budapest Hotel in 2014 at the same time
Dylan Hall quickly became a heartrob and
huge star himself and he remains one of
the most bankable names in Hollywood
looking back it's fair to wonder where
both actors would be had schwarzman not
left Donnie Darko around the turn of the
Millennium British actor Hugo weaving
played a pair of iconic roles he put on
elf ears to play Lord elrond and the
Lord of the Rings trilogy and a pair of
dark glasses to play agent Smith in The
Matrix in 2005 the adaptation of
alamar's FIFA Vendetta needed its mass
vigilante and weaving was chosen to
bring him to life but only after the
film's first pick James Purefoy left the
film in a half as Purefoy described it
he wasn't happy that nearly the entirety
of this role put him behind a mask and
what I am is a man in a mask pure Foy
may have some reason to regret his
decision though because the movie was
met with strong reviews even if it
wasn't a major bug office success more
importantly V Vendetta was a veritable
cultural Phenomenon with the imagery of
weaving's character and his grinning
mask becoming a symbol for an entire
generation of anti-establishment Youth
though pure Foy would quickly find
success on the small screen with Rome
the same year his big screen career
never did take off a string of bugs of
his bombs followed from Solomon Kane to
John Carter but who knows what may have
been had he gritted his teeth and played
the titular V
masor